former KKK leader and Louisiana Senate
candidate David Duke is really really
upset with the usual suspects Jews of
course and Democratic presidential
nominee Hillary Clinton he participated
in debate last night this is not a joke
at a historically black college you
could possibly make this stuff stuff up
this is where we are in 2016 USA David
Duke is an avid supporter of Donald
Trump he released a robocall campaign
and fundraising letters saying hey vote
Trump Duke they're both on the ticket in
Louisiana in part of Louisiana
now of course Donald Trump very slowly
but eventually disavowed support from
David Duke in February he initially said
I have no idea who David Duke is then he
said oh I do know who he is and I don't
want his support and during this debate
David Duke was asked by the moderator to
explain a blog post he wrote about quote
CNN Jews and Duke responded well there
is a problem in America with a very
strong powerful tribal group that
dominates our media dominates our
international banking I'm not opposed to
all Jews just like Donald Trump isn't
opposed to all Mexicans I guess he also
called for Hillary Clinton to be put to
death with the electric chair and he
continues to campaign on these
anti-semitic views he is not doing well
even in this race and it was reported
that university officials insisted we
didn't even know which candidates would
be here
we agreed to hold this debate and then
the the organizers decided based on
polling I guess David Duke polled 5% or
some some minimum that you need in order
to participate the organizers decided
that David Duke would be invited this is
just completely surreal isn't it former
KKK leader who loves Trump is
participating in a debate he's blaming
the Jews he's calling for the death of
Hillary Clinton in other countries they
laugh at us because this is considered
politics it's very real here well I
think the one saving grace is that we're
getting third fourth fifth Party
candidates into the debates right I mean
you're gonna get people who aren't
mainstream you're gonna get people who
represent
yeah the rate the rent is too damn high
party hat you have found somehow the
silver lining in a former KKK leader
participating in a debate which is that
it's showing us that it's more than just
the Democrat and the Republican leaders
participating it's a great job finding
the silver lining in this thing has any
I don't focus too much on physical
appearance but David Duke really looks
like he's wearing someone else's skin
doesn't he I remember the the movie men
in black where you have I think it's the
Vincent D'Onofrio character where it's
basically an alien that is wearing the
skin of this farmer that gets killed and
it's sort of like hanging off David Duke
has that same bizarre creepy appearance
you have to wonder if he's gotten some
work done maybe to appear more white
there yeah he and Michael Jackson both
have had the exact same thing done where
they just want to appear more white okay
so that's what's going on with David
Duke you can always sort of fall back to
insulting Jews if you're a radical
politician you can insult Jews and and
you'll have some support it's it's sort
of old faithful in America and that
there was a really funny comment from
the Public Service Commissioner Foster
Campbell after this debate who said I
have nothing in common with Duke other
than we're probably breathing which is
really funny because I don't know that
you've heard me say this to a guest
before Pat but sometimes when we
interview with some right-wing nut we
agree on nothing obviously at the end of
the interview I'll say I don't know that
we agreed on anything other than the
fact that we just did an interview for
15 minutes and it sort of reminded me of
that there's I have no agreement with
David Duke the only commonality is we
both appear to be breathing oxygen and I
guess are part of Homo sapiens although
even that I think is uh David Duke is
regularly putting casting doubt on